what's inside the world's largest sphere
to find out I went to Las Vegas for an
exclusive demo put on by some Big Boys
in entertainment and audio and holy moly
this thing is massive for context the
Epcot Center is this big
the Montreal biosphere this big
but the sphere in Vegas is big enough to
fit the Statue of Liberty but that scale
and that shape is a nightmare of
acoustic sound Engineers also sound
system is hidden behind a dome of LED
panels so to figure out how to literally
beam sound past the wall using
algorithms to customize the experience
for everyone all this guided by matrix
array speakers which are like line
arrays but more sophisticated and Dave
rat will tell you how nice light arrays
sound sounded like the PA was closer
than it physically looked it was kind of
a messing with my mind it was how can it
sound so close and look so far I'd never
heard anything like that before it's a
completely immersive Visual and audio
experience brought To Us by two of the
biggest names in the bids and that's
only a very small part of